herr doktor wissen sie mein immunsystem
das ist ja so schwach ich bin ständig
krank können sie da nicht was machen das
immunsystem unendliche weiten
immunsystem was ist das eigentlich und
was kann man da wirklich tun um es zu
stärken
darum geht es in diesem video jeder
spricht davon aber wenige wissen was ist
das eigentlich dieses immunsystem
wo sitzt das eigentlich ist das ein
organe wie die leber oder die lunge wie
der name system schon andeutet gibt es
nicht den einen sitz dass eine organ das
sich um unsere immunabwehr kümmert
sondern es ist eben ein system an dem
viele elemente beteiligt sind
spezialisierte zellen botenstoffe und
ganze organe oder teile davon
dazu gehören von außen angefangen unsere
haut und vor allem die schleimhäute zum
beispiel von nase und rachen aber auch
der gesamte damen gehört dazu das macht
ja auch sinn denn über diese öffnungen
gelangen ja viele stoffe und substanzen
auch eindringlinge also bakterien viren
pilze und parasiten also schlicht alle
möglichen erreger in unseren körper die
meisten von ihnen werden an diesen
schleimhäuten schon unschädlich gemacht
außerdem überleben viele erreger das
saure milieu in unserem magen nicht auch
das ist eine form der abwehr aber auch
das knochenmark gehört zum immunsystem
dort werden die abwehrzellen die
sogenannten b zellen und vorläufer davon
gebildet b-zellen heißen so weil knochen
auf englisch halt baum heißt ganz
einfach die zweite zelle hat die eine
rolle spielt sind die t zellen und die
heißen so weil sie im thymus ausreifen
in den lymphknoten und bahnen wandern
die verschiedenen abwehrzellen hin und
her sie werden dort auch gespeichert
auch die milz speichert abwehrzellen man
kann das ganze immunsystem
unterschiedlich einteilen einer
einteilung ist zum beispiel die
unterscheidung in die angeborene und die
erworbene abwehr die angeborene abwehr
bekommen wir sozusagen als
grundausstattung mit
sie besteht aus zellen der weißen
blutkörperchen so genannte fresszellen
das klingt ja schon ziemlich grob und
allgemein und das ist es auch denn diese
zellen sind nicht auf bestimmte erreger
spezialisiert sie vernichten nach
möglichkeit alles was da nicht hingehört
deshalb nennt man diese art der abwehr
auch unspezifische abwehr oder
natürliche abwehr eine zweite
verteidigungslinie besteht in der
erworbenen abwehr auch spezifische
abwehr genannt hauptakteure der
spezifischen abwehr sind die b zellen
die aus dem knochenmark
dort werden sie gebildet und gelangen
dann in die lymphknoten und in emails
das besondere an den zellen ist an
diesen b-zellen dass sie die erreger
nicht selbst angreifen sondern dazu
antikörper bilden das sind diese oft die
eine pcie londa gestellten proteine
immunglobuline genannt und zwar
produzieren die zellen ganz spezielle
jeweils auf einen ganz bestimmten
erreger passende antikörper also zb
gegen das corona wie rosa skoff 2 dazu
müssen diese t-zellen natürlich erst
einmal kontakt gehabt haben zu dem
jeweiligen erreger dieser art
immunabwehr mit antikörpern nennt man
deshalb auch erworbene abwehr
das heißt aber auch dass sie nicht beim
ersten kontakt mit dem entsprechenden
erreger zum beispiel virus zur verfügung
steht sondern diese t-zellen die müssen
erst angelernt werden
dann aber ist die bauanleitung für diese
speziellen antikörper für lange zeit
abgelegt denn so genannte
gedächtniszellen merken sich den
speziellen erreger zum beispiel saß kopf
wenn der dann später mal wieder im
körper auftaucht kurbeln diese
gedächtniszellen die produktion der
spezifischen antikörper ganz kräftig an
so dass das virus idealerweise schon vor
einer infektion unschädlich gemacht wird
wie lange sich das immunsystem an den
entsprechenden erreger erinnert das ist
unterschiedlich so weiß man zum beispiel
bei saas kauf zwei noch nicht wie lange
die immunabwehr nach einer infektion
anhält
bei einer impfung egal mit welcher art
impfstoff passiert genau das selbe wie
bei einem kontakt mit einem krank machen
den erreger nur mit dem wichtigen
unterschied dass man mit der impfung dem
immunsystem nur vorgaukelt da käme ein
böser erreger in wirklichkeit kommt aber
nur ein harmloses teil des erregers oder
einer der sich gar nicht vermehren kann
da er aber zumindest in teilen so
aussieht wie der bösewicht stellt das
immunsystem genau diese antikörper her
wie es das auch beim echten erreger
machen würde häufig sogar noch
intensiver als nach der natürlichen
infektion
das ist zb nach einer corona impfung der
fall
doch damit nicht genug außer den
antikörpern zählen auch bestimmte zellen
zur spezifischen abwehr und das sind die
schon erwähnten t-zellen die werden
nämlich auch sowohl bei der echten
infektion als auch bei einer impfung
speziell passend zu den entsprechenden
erregern gebildet mit einem antikörper
test den man ja machen kann um zum
beispiel herauszufinden ob man schon
krone hatte oder nicht
misst man natürlich nur die antikörper
die zelluläre immunabwehr also die t
zellen die erfasst man damit nicht
deshalb kann es sein dass man obwohl man
keine antikörper gegen korona findet
trotzdem möglicherweise schon eine
corona infektion hat würde man auch die
t zellen untersuchen was nicht so
einfach ist würde man da vielleicht
spezielle gegen das corona virus
gebildete t zellen finden
bei jungen menschen ist auch das
immunsystem jung und leistungsfähig
leider bleibt das nicht so es altert mit
uns und natürlich ist ein gutes
immunsystem wünschenswert aber auch ein
gutes immunsystem kann zb eine corona
infektion meist nicht komplett
verhindern
aber es kann den unterschied machen
zwischen wenigen und schweren symptomen
und wie stärkt man es nun dieses
immunsystem was man schon vermuten kann
es gibt nicht die eine pille oder die
eine maßnahme die alles richtet dazu ist
das system einfach zu komplex es hat zu
viele verschiedene angriffspunkte oft
wird ja das vitamin d genannt wenn es um
die stärkung der abwehrkräfte geht und
sicher gehört eine ausreichende vitamin
und nährstoffversorgung dazu viele
studien die dazu gemacht wurden haben
auch gezeigt dass menschen mit einem
geringen vitamin-d-spiegel infekt
anfälliger sind aber statistisch sind
darunter eben viele ältere oder kranke
menschen alter und auch viele
krankheiten schwächen die abwehrkräfte
gehen aber auch unabhängig davon mit
einem niedrigeren vitamin-d-spiegel
einher so stellt sich dann immer die
frage ist es tatsächlich das niedrige
vitamin d oder ist es das alter an sich
die isolierte gabe von vitamin d führt
dann oft nicht zum gewünschten erfolg
richtig ist auf jeden fall dass man
keinen echten mangel an vitaminen und
nährstoffen haben sollte das vitamin d
spielt ja eine sonderrolle
aber grundsätzlich reicht in den meisten
fällen das zu tun was uns generell
gesund hält und was wir alle schon
tausendmal gehört haben eine ausgewogene
ernährung mit viel gemüse und obst
ballaststoffen ausreichend bewegung kein
übergewicht nicht rauchen und ja eine
positive lebenseinstellung
dazu gibt es ein eigenes
forschungsgebiet die psycho neuro
immunologie und die hat ganz klar aus
gefunden
eine positive lebenseinstellung stärkt
unser immunsystem noch was gehört dazu
und das kostet ebenfalls keinen cent
ausreichend schlaf
forscher der universitäten lübeck und
tübingen fanden jetzt heraus wie schlaf
das immunsystem stärkt er führt unter
anderem zu einer besseren funktion der t
zellen sie können besser an den feind an
den erreger bin ein gutes immunsystem
ist also von vorteil nicht nur bei einer
echten infektion damit der körper die
erreger besser bekämpfen kann und
deshalb geringere symptome entwickelt
sondern auch bei einer impfung weil ein
starkes immunsystem auch eine starke
immunantwort wie man das nennt
hervorruft alles was es dazu braucht
haben wir selbst mit unserem lebensstil
in der hand und kostet nichts
[Musik]